bonjour je suis je suis l'un des
associés de réunion édition réunion
édition est une société d'édition et une
régie publicitaire nous commercialisons
à la Réunion plusieurs journaux
magazines et support publicitaire le CHR
journal qui est le journal professionnel
des caftiers hôteliers restaurateur
presse et communication qui est le
magazine de la presse des médias et de
la communication à la Réunion pil
spocket qui est un magazine culturel
nous sommes également propriétairees du
réseau flashcard qui est un réseau de
carte postal publicitaire
nous sommes également régie publicitaire
de de support l'écoustral le magazine
économique de l'éan indien et G
affffichage qui est un réseau
d'affichage urbain aujourd'hui réunion
édition se compose de deux associés donc
Emmanuel Robert et moi-même deux
commerciaux un graphiste pour toute la
partie maquette et montage également
deux rédacteurs en chef pour le CHR
journal et presse et communication et
nous avons également un service de
livraison pour assurer justement le
réassort des campagnes flashcard et la
livraison des pill spocket au lieu de
distribution réunion édition cherche
aujourd'hui un livreur qui fasse le
réassort des campagne flashcard sur
toute l'île et qui livre également le
magazine pil spocket sur l'ensemble de
ses points de distribution on recherche
quelqu'un qui sache s'intégrer à une
équipe puisque cette personne devra
travailler en relation avec la direction
commerciale de réunion édition ce
livreur devra bien entendu disposer du
permis de conduire c'est un poste à
mi-temps que l'on propose il nous faut
quelqu'un de rigoureux quelqu'un qui
sache travailler en autonomie quelqu'un
qui connaisse bien la géographie de
l'île puisque il va falloir aller un
petit peu partout sur les 270 points de
distribution du réseau il faut également
bien sûr quelqu'un qui soit dynamique de
sourillance ser le représentant direct
de la marque flashcard auprès des
patrons d'établissements dans lesquels
se trouent les panneaux
flashcard si ce poste vous intéresse et
que vous voulez intégrer une équipe
jeune et dynamique n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter à
bientôt bonjour je m'appelle C St j'ai
19 ans je viens de Saint-Pierre mon
métier est conducteur
d'engin je suis en formation et RM de
Saint-Pierre j'ai passé mon casss 1 410
j'ai réussi et j'ai fais beaucoup de
travaille là-bas comme faire des
tranchées trouver des fuites d'eau
travailler aussi en
précision je suis disponible sur toute
l'Î en professionnel ben j'aime le
travail soigné soit propre j'aime
travailler en équipe avec une équipe
dynamique je bouge beaucoup ben j'aime
bien m'investir dans le travail si ma
candidature vous plaît choisissez c'est
moi à bientôt je
l'espère bonjour je m'appelle grimoire
els j'ai 21 ans j'habite à la possession
j'ai le permis B je possède un véhicule
j'aimerais faire un CP pâtisserie en
apprentissage je suis actuellement 2e
année de BTS assistante de gestion de
PME PMI je n'ai pas de formation
particulière concernant la pâtisserie
mais j'ai déjà assisté mon père qui éta
é lui pâtissier je fais pas mal de
préparations de gâteaux chez moi comme
des tartes aux pommes aux fraises des
génoises des crèmes pâtissières aussi
cependant j'ai effectuer pas mal de
stages dans des entreprises je recherche
une pâtisserie dans l'Ouest prête à
m'accueillir plus tard j'aimerais créer
une pâtisserie c'est pour cela que
j'aimerais faire ce CP pâtisserie
dans le but d'apprendre la pratique en
sachant que j'ai déjà une base en
gestion cela reste un avantage pour moi
je suis très motivé vous ne serez pas
déçu par mon travail bonjour Patrice g
j'ai 23 ans j'habite sur la possession
j'ai le PMB j'ai un petit garçon mon
objectif professionnel à moi c'est de
devenir responsable d'exploitation ou
responsable d'entrepôt en 2009 j'ai
obtenu mon bac stg spécialité mcatique
ensuite j'ai travaillé un peu et je me
suis vite remis dans le chemin formation
parce que ça me'est nulle part donc j'ai
entrepris de faire un tite de vendeur
conseil en magasin que j'ai effectué en
parallèle dans une chaîne de
restauration rapide et là j'aimerais
bien intégrer un BTS Transport en
alternance euh mes qualités pour ce
poste sont le sourire je suis quelqu'un
de très sociable et je suis déterminé
moi ce qui me plaît dans ce poste c'est
le responsabilité lié au métier et la
stabilité j'espère avoir retenu votre
attention et j'espère ma candidature
pour
fruit contactez-nous sur notre page
facebook
www.facebook.com/974 TV ou par téléphone
0262 92
3760 974 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la Réunion